à quarrata numérique
sagesse qui vont du ghetto comité pour
la paix
maintenir cette affaire
[Applaudissements]
ils ont flairé une autre piste courez
[Musique]
les fleurs surtout
mais pas m
mais tu es complètement malade il va
jamais s'en tirer dit le fond me soit 40
de la lumière et des rebelles me protège
que ta sagesse divine
regarde moi juste derrière cette porte
des montagnes d'or nous attendent
non chers jeunes chères ce que la la
connaissance je sais oui
et maintenant brise soleil ouvre nous
cette porte
pour obtenir plus
par trois des hommes par trois la voix
ouvriront le sans mordre ça n'a aucun
sens
le sang voilà c'est ça la clé
tu es le seuil d'accès quoi
j'ai besoin de personne ne les retient
alors il il est écrit que le sort de
plein gré doit se réveiller
non mais dites moi que je rêve
toorop
sa masse
pour lui venir en aide c'est trop tard
pour lui
c'est triste qu'il soit mort
après tout c'est la vie ça sera plus
simple de diviser leur endroit
il est forcément quelque part par là des
chiffres ça donne
par trois des hommes par trois la voix
ouvriront par le sand plein gré alors
que l'euro aux créateurs quoi gloire à
la fidh
non non non notre or dans tout ça ou est
ce qu on sait qu s'est fourvoyé il
s'agit d'une invocation se refuse de
continuer on est venu ici pour un trésor
c'est quoi cet endroit je ne sais pas
c'est peut-être peut-être 4 septembre où
tu te rend beau
le son on est la clé
[Applaudissements]
unis soit 40 quant à lui me jeter en
elle le protège qu'est-ce que ça jase de
ville maudite comité mais pour mattel du
mont ham virta lui dire ses crêpes des
huiles apporte nous le seul
par trois des hommes
[Musique]
3la vous moi devrions
par 102 plein gré
[Musique]
nous tablons anton royaux
bien fermer les yeux
[Musique]
il n'y a pas de lumière ici tu es venu
chercher la connaissance dans les
ténèbres
oui et tout le savoir que tu cherches
est ici sous mais toi prononce les mots
à la mène par 3 des hommes
par trois
la voix offriront
[Musique]
par le sang versé de plein gré
nuri sahin pourquoi
donneront
[Musique]
plus rare
pas bête
felip de là
créatrice
quelles sont tués
kohat
hachey
[Musique]
béni soit hummer
sauf nous
[Musique]